bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors est ce que c'est un
peu compliqué pour dubaï donne de parler
d'un côté de politique migratoire
humaines et de l'autre de mentonnière le
fait par année de réfugiés fixé par
donald trump williams confusion aux
états unis entre les migrantes qui
viennent à la frontière qui cherchent
l'asile et réfugiées dans l'école au
hainaut en afrique ou d'ailleurs qui
sont passés sous une procédure de
vêtements et qui était agréé pour
rentrer aux états unis et les autres
types c'est mal perçu et pour sabrer
dénoncés ils veulent laisser ce sujet
c'est trop chaud maman il a autres
objectifs à accomplir
ils en ont un programme de relance
économique
et pour bien au point mort le question
de réfugiés n'est pas en priorité de
l'administration bad est donc oui
c'était un coup dur pour les groupes de
défense des réfugiés mais c'est
compréhensible dans les centres première
heure d'administration pride
il veut pas avoir naufrage comme en
parlant avait avec les systèmes réforme
du système de santé a donné assez
conservatrice se questionner et un sur
le rétropédalage montre qu'elle est
susceptible de la gauche du parti
démocrate
mais ils n'ont pas pris en otage et
pourtant il est ses promesses de
campagne en étant plus des restrictions
anti migrants de donald trump il ya eu
pas mal de bananes disait vraiment
vouloir tourner cette page
c'est vraiment une question de temps
c'est pour cette raison qu'on ne l'a pas
fait vraiment oui si les optiques donc
actuellement petite crise sur la
frontière avec les migrantes et c'est
marc gérer
avec lui il a offert de régularisation
de grosses nombre des immigrés et les
gares il arrivait tout un pan de type
pour attirer le voit hispanique est
minoritaire
mais maintenant que l'élection est fini
où lé promesses rien ce sont que des
promesses et si on tient pas les
promesses
ok les responsables dans les prochaines
élections présidentielles mais entre
temps par d'énormes agents des
législatives il veut gagner la gauche
parce qu'il a besoin de le voir mais il
il veut pas créer plus de problèmes avec
les centristes les républicains et le
reste qui joue bien sûr sur le registre
de chercheurs d'asile et migrants dans
la maison blanche avait trop pédales et
assuré qu'il ne s'agissait d'une
décision seulement provisoire que ce
taux serait revue à la hausse d'ici la
mi mai est-ce que vous et non pas du
tout je pense le pronostic était
dégradée fixe le cap à 13 mieux parce
que il n'ya pas les voir dans sept
d'entre eux
c'est un show significative et lectures
helmand
mais bien sûr le retour d'alice était
essentiel pour garder des clous de
galles jobs qui loupait de majorité dans
le senate a dit que c'est inacceptable
il a besoin de chaque voie dans les
cénacles maintenant ou dix autres
programmes donc il dit oui après
jusqu'ici a mis 15
c'était c'est seulement une manoeuvre
politique c'est pas crédible alors on va
parler de politique internationale à
cette fois ci est ce que vous trouvez
que donne elle peut joe biden est si
différent et que donald trump
oui du coup il est très différent
d'abord dans son style qui n'est pas
provocatrice
dans l'appréciation des états unis mais
le politique étrangère des etats-unis
s'est toujours basé sur les entrées
nationales et l'a1 voix en continuité
entre les présidents de républiques néo
démocrate il ya un certain nombre de
politiques qui restent fixes mais les
différences de politiques un peu on peut
noter que maintenant on annonce le
retrait d'afghanistan
mais c'était déjà la politique de 30 et
avança d'obama donc cas oui mais plutôt
dans le style que dans le fond donc la
fayette vous êtes professeur de droit
spécialiste de sciences politiques
américaines merci à vous